A walking nightmare and a machete wielding
killer clashed 20 years ago in "Freddy vs
Jason," and fans have been begging for a sequel
ever since. Here's why it hasn't happened yet.
The "Nightmare on Elm Street" and "Friday the
13th" franchises were both popular, profitable
series in the '80s and '90s. Freddy's last film
was almost a decade earlier, and the previous
Jason flick had been a flop. So when "Freddy
vs. Jason" landed in 2003, combining them into
a crossover film, it re-energized both characters
and wound up pulling in the highest box office
gross for both franchises. With an estimated
$116 million dollar haul on a $30 million dollar
budget, it was a huge money maker, and you'd
think it would have led to a second crossover.
Unfortunately, attempts to get a "Freddy vs.
Jason" sequel have been stalled for years. It
wasn't helped by the fact that both franchises
opted to reboot their respective series,
with a new "Friday the 13th" arriving
in 2009, and a remake of "Nightmare
on Elm Street" a year later. Neither were
successful enough to warrant follow-ups.
At the same time, the movie rights
to Jason and the "Friday the 13th"
series were soon caught in a complicated
legal web that has never been cleared up.
Attempts to make a sequel to "Freddy vs.
Jason" went further than just pairing up
the two villains for a second bout,
however. Looking for a fresh spin,
the studio tried adding a third character, and
it seems that they settled on one in particular:
Ash Williams from "Evil Dead." Played
by Bruce Campbell, the chainsaw-wielding
warrior would have matched up well against
the machete and claws of Jason and Freddy.
The idea actually stems from an Easter
egg in "Jason Goes to Hell," where a
copy of the Necronomicon from "Evil Dead"
is implied to be responsible for Jason's
power. According to a "SyFy" interview with
that film's director, Adam Marcus, he was,
quote, "setting up a mythology that Jason's
mom wanted her son back so badly that she
reads from the Necronomicon and brings about
the resurrection of her son." As a result,
the notion to cross all three franchises
together seemed like a natural fit.
Unfortunately, getting the rights to
both Freddy and Jason was hard enough,
but wrangling "Evil Dead" on top of it proved
nearly impossible. Bruce Campbell, meanwhile,
wasn't all that excited about the concept, and
eventually, he walked away. He said on Reddit,
"I'm not real interested in crossovers. One
of the main reasons why 'Ash vs. Jason vs.
Freddy' did not come to pass is because
we couldn't control any other character
other than Ash. That felt like a
creatively bankrupt way to go."
"This guy's behind everything."
"Wow, there's an overstatement."
As the rumors of a three-way battle
with Ash in a sequel gained steam,
the film's director, Ronny Yu, addressed the
gossip in 2004. Speaking to "Creature Corner"
about the possibility of merging
the three franchises, he said,
"That's something that the studio
came up with. They asked me,
and all the fans wanted me to do it as well,
so I said, 'Yes, show me the script!' I would
definitely do it. They're still working
on the script, I haven't seen anything."
Sadly, Yu's jab at the long development
time was frighteningly prescient,
and nothing has yet to come of it some 20 years
later. And he's not the only one who's been
frustrated by the lack of movement. The original
film's writers, Damian Shannon and Mark Swift,
are still holding out for a sequel to
come to fruition. In 2020, they tweeted,
"We still want to get it made."
As for the cast, Freddy actor and
star Robert Englund expressed his
regret that they didn't do a sequel while
chatting with "Too Fab" in 2020. He said,
"I think that remakes were rushed. I know
the remake on 'A Nightmare on Elm Street'
was premature. We should have done another
'Freddy vs. Jason' film and then waited,
they should have waited for five or 10 years."
As we've already discussed, one of the
reasons a sequel hasn't come yet is that
both franchises have since seen clean-slate
reboots. New actors were brought in,
with Jackie Earle Haley putting on the
striped sweater to play Freddy and future
"Swamp Thing" actor Derek Mears donning the
hockey mask as Jason. Though the 2009 version
of "Friday the 13th" did okayish at the box
office, neither film got a sequel of its own,
but one of the ideas thrown around by fans is to
essentially do what both franchises did in 2003.
They want to create a crossover mash-up movie
to re-energize both series at the same time.
Recent wild rumors and fan's desires aside,
there's some logic to the notion. Even if
it's unlikely that we'd get Ash Williams, a
battle between the rebooted killers could be
a winning idea with the right script, a solid
director, and perhaps some legacy actors from
both franchises returning to make a splash.
In fact, during a 2008 conversation with MTV,
Derek Mears even said he'd love to do a "Freddy
vs. Jason" sequel, although at the time,
Jackie Earle Haley hadn't been publicly
announced for the "Nightmare" reboot
yet and Mears was saying how he'd love
to throw down against Robert Englund.
"I've been away from my
children for far too long."
Unlike most sequels stuck in development hell, we
know a lot about what the sequel to "Freddy vs.
Jason" would have been about. That's because in
2004, "Bloody Disgusting" actually published the
screen treatment on their website for all to see.
It was a version that incorporated Ash Williams,
and it begins where "Army of Darkness"
and "Freddy vs. Jason" left off. Ash is
searching for the Necronomicon, the town
of Crystal Lake has been redeveloped,
and Jason's house — where the
book resides — is to be torn down.
According to the treatment, Freddy is
"clinging to life" inside Jason's mind,
and the film opens with Lori Campbell and Will
Rollins returning to Crystal Lake to make sure
both villains are truly dead. After a frightening
quick-kill sequence, we meet our heroes,
a group of teens working at a new S-Mart — the
store where Ash works — built in the new Crystal
Lake. But when Jason learns of the Necronomicon,
he plans to use it to free Freddy from his mind
and resurrect his mother. He's not the only one
who knows the book is in Crystal Lake though, and
Ash has arrived to find it too, leading him into
a showdown with both Freddy and Jason, with the
help of his fellow S-Mart employees. Ultimately,
"Freddy vs. Jason vs. Ash" would have turned the
two villains into reluctant allies while sending
in Bruce Campbell's Ash to stop them both.
Unfortunately, one of the biggest reasons
that a sequel hasn't happened to this point
is that actor Robert Englund —
the only man to portray Freddy
Krueger until 2010 — is no longer
interested in playing the character.
"I won't don the fedora or strap on the claws
again, because I'm just a little too old."
Englund doubled down on this
in 2023, telling "Variety,"
"I'm too old and thick to play Freddy
now. I just can't do fight scenes for
more than one take anymore. I've got a
bad neck and bad back and arthritis in
my right wrist. So I have to hang
it up, but I would love to cameo."
However, the horror actor did suggest that
Kevin Bacon might make for a good Freddy,
saying the way he moves might
be perfect for the part.
With all that said, however, if the screen
treatment that had been leaked by "Bloody
Disgusting" had ever been made, we know it
would have starred Englund and Bruce Campbell,
as well as Monica Keena and Jason Ritter,
returning as survivors Lori and Will. Keena
even addressed the possibility recently while
talking with the podcast Happy Horror Time,
revealing that both she and Ritter had options
for a sequel in their contract for the first film.
Of course, it's also likely that Ken Kirzinger
would have reprised his role as Jason too,
and he may even still be up for a return
if somehow a "Freddy vs. Jason" follow-up
could ever be made. He made this clear
during an appearance at a panel during
the Spookala Horror Convention in 2022, saying,
"If they asked me to do that,
I'd be very happy to come back."
It's been two decades since "Freddy
vs. Jason" first hit theaters,
but what you might not know is that there is
indeed a continuation of the story — just not
on film. The crossover sequel took place in
comic book form, a joint production between DC
Comics imprint Wildstorm and New Jersey-based
independent publisher Dynamite Entertainment.
Titled "Freddy vs. Jason vs. Ash," the
six-issue miniseries was published in
2007 and written by James Kuhoric from a story
by Jeff Katz, the writer of the planned movie.
Following that original treatment more or
less, the story sees Freddy resurrected by
Jason through the use of the Necronomicon. At
the same time, Ash Williams arrives in Crystal
Lake looking for the cursed book, and an epic
battle ensues, with Freddy resurrecting all
of Jason's previous victims as Deadites that
Ash must slay. But what makes this sequel so
unique is that it even received a sequel of its
own, "Freddy vs. Jason vs. Ash: The Nightmare
Warriors," published in 2009, and once again
written by Kuhoric, based on a story from Katz.
This time around, the U.S. government
tries to control Freddy and Jason's powers,
only to unleash them once again on an
unsuspecting populace. Then it's up to
Ash to join forces with former survivors of both
madmen to bring them down and save the world.
Given that "Freddy vs. Jason" brought together two
iconic horror franchises, it makes sense that it
amassed a bigger audience than either had achieved
alone. Even after 20 years of frustration,
fans are still hoping that they'll finally get
a chance to see Freddy and Jason together again.
"The only thing to fear is fear itself."
Over on Change.org, a petition to get a "Freddy
vs. Jason" sequel collected signatures from
thousands of supporters who were hoping to get
Hollywood's attention. While nothing came of it,
it did show just how passionate the movie's fans
are. Likewise, over on Reddit, "Freddy vs. Jason
vs. Ash" often pops up in discussions of
horror sequels fans still want to see,
and it remains a hot topic of conversation
to this day. Even the press is still in love,
with articles, podcasts, and websites
continuing to publish discussions that
ponder the possibilities of a
part two even decades later.
There are many challenges to overcome to make
a "Freddy vs. Jason" sequel happen. A new story
and script will have to be assembled given
Bruce Campbell's disinterest in a crossover,
and Robert Englund will have to be convinced to
return, or be replaced by a new Freddy. The legal
rights to the "Friday the 13th" series will
have to be cleared up, which is no easy feat,
while the studio will have to be convinced that
such a crossover, 20 years later, can still work.
But even with all that in mind,
there's definitely a way it can happen.
When it comes to the legal problems,
studios have shown that when there's
money to be made and a blockbuster to be
produced, there's not much they won't do
to get the rights they need to make it
happen. For proof, look no further than
Sony's unprecedented deal with Marvel
to incorporate Spider-Man into the MCU.
We admit, it's probably a longshot with
everything that's working against it,
but it's what the fans clearly crave, and with
crossovers and cinematic universes all the rage,
it could stand to make big box office bucks.